Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
de Louis, qui me pose la question :
« Les Autochtones ne paient-ils réellement
pas de taxes, d'impôts et d'électricité? »
Louis, cette question-là,
elle est tellement vieille et elle a une vie
d'elle-même parce qu'on y a répondu
plusieurs fois, mais ça s'est mélangé
aussi avec des concepts et ç'a eu l'effet
de créer une légende urbaine qui veut
que les Premières Nations, on ne paie rien :
pas de taxes et d'impôts, pas d'électricité.
Il y a une réalité, c'est celle que si
tu es un Indien inscrit sous la Loi sur les Indiens
et que tu vis
sur une réserve,
c'est vrai que tu ne paies pas de taxe
de services sur les produits
que tu achètes sur la réserve.
C'est vrai aussi que tu n'as pas d'impôts
qui sont pris sur ton salaire
que tu gagnes sur la réserve.
Mais, aussitôt que tu sors de la réserve
et que tu n'es pas dans un territoire
autochtone, tu paies des impôts, tu paies
des taxes. Moi, si je gagne mon salaire
à Montréal présentement, je paie de l'impôt.
Et si je décide de ne pas le payer, je peux
te dire que comme n'importe quel autre Québécois,
ils vont venir me chercher assez vite.
Pour ce qui est de l'hydroélectricité,
c'est la même chose.
On paie l'hydroélectricité. Il y a des fois
des ententes territoriales qui peuvent être
faites entre une nation et Hydro-Québec
parce qu'ils vont faire de l'exploitation
d'hydroélectricité sur leur territoire,
parce qu'il a des lignes
à haute tension qui vont passer
sur les territoires autochtones. Mais ces ententes
se font avec la communauté.
Et beaucoup de communautés paient aussi
leur électricité, sinon ils se font couper,
comme n'importe qui d'autre.
Je te dirais que si jamais on ne payait pas
notre hydroélectricité, qu'on avait
de l'électricité gratuite,
autant qu'on en voudrait, les réserves
seraient illuminées comme des sapins de Noël.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
La raison pourquoi cette question revient
si souvent, c'est que les gens ont pris
en tête qu'on avait un avantage,
presque que comme une personne nantie.
On le sait que dans les communautés autochtones,
on n'est pas les nations les plus nanties au Canada.
Mais, la raison pourquoi
on a été exemptés de taxes et d'impôts
sur les réserves, c'est que quand
on était sur les réserves, justement,
on était considérés comme des enfants
aux yeux de la loi. On était sous tutelle.
Des personnes sous tutelle ne paieront pas d'impôts
ou de taxes parce que ce sont des enfants.
Donc, ils ont accès à des services tels
que les soins de santé sur la réserve,
qui sont liés au fait qu'ils sont
des Indiens inscrits. Pour tout ce qui est
des détails d'exemption de taxes,
des fois des fraudes qui sont faites avec
des fausses cartes d'Indiens, il faut
que tu ailles dans les nouvelles.
Tu vas voir, c'est toujours des cas par cas.
Mais dans l'ensemble, ce n'est vraiment pas
une réalité comme quoi on roule sur l'or
et qu'on reçoit un chèque
parce qu'on est des Indiens inscrits, ou bien
parce qu'on ne paie pas de taxes
et d'impôts. Il y a vraiment
une réalité qu'on en paie.
Et si jamais on venait un jour
à ne plus avoir la Loi sur les Indiens,
probablement qu'un système de taxes
et d'impôts s'imbriquerait dans la vie
sur réserve pour justement payer
pour les services qui, autrefois,
quand on était sous tutelle, a été pris en charge
par le fédéral. Mais il ne faut pas oublier
que si on enlève la tutelle, on redonne
des territoires qui sont présentement encore
sous la main du fédéral et du provincial.
Est-ce que c'est plus payant de nous
garder sous tutelle?
C'est l'impression que ça donne,
puisque la Loi sur les Indiens n'a pas
encore été enlevée et n'a pas été encore
négociée avec les communautés
pour être retirée comme loi.
Donc, j'espère avoir même effleuré
un peu la question pour toi.
N'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions,
n'hésitez pas à partager ces vidéos.
Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine